with a high profile release of zack
snyder's justice league fans are
wondering whether the newest dc film
release will get a sequel
especially since the director's cut
wraps up with a big old cliffhanger
so let's dig into the big question the
4-hour epic leaves us with will the
story continue
zack snyder's justice league ends with
what clearly seems to be a setup for a
sequel
after an escape lex luthor tells
deathstroke that batman is bruce wayne
batman has yet another dream about the
nightmare reality in which he
deathstroke the flash cyborg mira the
joker and an out evil superman
are traversing the earth after an
apocalypse upon waking from his
unsettling dream bruce is greeted by the
martian manhunter who had previously
been masquerading as general calvin
swanwick and even disguised himself as
superman's adopted mother martha to
speak to lois lane
manhunter reveals his true identity to
batman expresses his gratitude for
bringing the justice league together
and tells him that they'll speak again
to discuss what darkseid is going to do
next
if zack snyder's justice league had been
released in theaters as the one and only
version of the movie with no
joss whedon cuts and no campaign to make
the snyder cut a reality a sequel would
probably happen
if you followed the first two movies
this movie really kind of takes you
into a completely immersive scope and
scale
reviews for zack snyder's justice league
have been largely positive with critics
giving him a 73
approval rating on rotten tomatoes an
audience is handing it a 96
score the film is dominating the pop
culture conversation
basically if the movie had been released
under different circumstances warner
brothers would be silly not to green
light a sequel
but zack snyder's justice league is what
it is a director's cut of a movie that
already came out in a very different
form in 2017.
snyder himself has said that he ended
the movie on a cliffhanger simply
because that's what he would have done
originally
not because of future plans he told ign
i wanted to just release the movie
exactly as it was designed
and that is what that scene is really
indicative of snyder also explained that
he could have crafted an ending that
felt more definitive and didn't leave
things open-ended
but that didn't feel genuine or
satisfying he said it's in
genre to end these movies on a
cliffhanger that's kind of how they are
and i just felt like that's what i
wanted to do
so is snyder even interested in
directing and writing the sequel
the director's answer to that question
is likely to disappoint many fans even
as it offers a slight glimmer of hope
in january 2021 snyder said in an
interview with comic book debate that he
has no plans to continue on with the dc
eu in the future
but he admitted that he never thought
he'd really be in a position to release
his version of justice league in the
first place so there's a very small
chance things could change
look i never thought i'd be here doing
this i didn't think i'd be finishing
justice league
as far as what i did and my vision for
what i wanted to do with these
characters and the journey i wanted them
to go on
it's well known that i planned on more
movies five movies or something but i'm
busy
i've got a lot going on is it cool that
the fans have so much faith in the
trajectory
yes it's amazing and i couldn't be
happier and i'm excited for them to see
justice
league so they can really drink the
entire elixir of justice league but
would i continue
i have no plan to but like i said i
didn't think i'd be here so who knows
snyder broached the subject again at ign
fanfest in late february 2021 making it
seem as though he might be more amenable
to revisiting his justice league world
at some point when asked if he would
consider directing a sequel snyder said
that's very hypothetical i think that i
would say i would believe it when i see
it
and happy to cross that bridge when i
see it approaching uh anything is
possible clearly
of course the key decision makers when
it comes to whether there will be
another snyder directed justice league
are the executives at warner brothers
and dc entertainment which fall under
the parent company warner media all was
quiet on that front in the lead up to
the snyder cuts hbo max debut
then on monday march 22nd warner media
got candid about where things are going
from here
in short the media conglomerate
maintains that zack snyder's justice
league is the last dc movie he'll ever
make
ann sarnoff ceo of warner media studios
told variety that zack snyder's justice
league brings the director's trilogy to
an end
that trilogy is 2013's man of steel it's
2016 sequel batman vs superman dawn of
justice and now zack snyder's justice
league
when asked about the campaign to quote
restore the snyder verse and allow
snyder to create more movies in the dc
eu
startup said the snyder cuts is a one
and done situation and dc plans to move
forward with other plans
she said i appreciate that they love
zack's work and we are very thankful for
his many contributions to dc
we're just so happy that he could bring
his cut of the justice league to life
because that wasn't in the plan until
about a year ago
with that comes the completion of his
trilogy we're very happy we've done this
but we're very excited about the plans
we have for all the multi-dimensional dc
characters that are being developed
right now
so it seems that cliffhangers and band
campaigns aren't enough to make his
second zack snyder's justice league
happen
in the end at least one snyder cut got
to see the light of day
and that was a pretty unlikely
occurrence itself
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
the dc eu are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
you